yaghi guillot tâche vous rappelez degré
guyotat qui se faisait passer pour un
infirmier
oui il ya des piqûres on a fait une
deuxième elle est encore au dessus de la
première les mecs pète un plomb
regardez tuto pour regarder pour faire
des prises de sang regarder greg liotta
c'est parti je vais vous demander de me
suivre la gare déjà juste vérifier un
petit frère parce que j'ai un petit
doute sur quelque chose
la firme utilise des bulles sous vide on
observa dans ce dessein caractéristiques
la veine basilique label ces familles et
entre les deux la veine médiane cubital
et votre vin nommé diane capitale c'est
là qu'elle l'a ce qu'ils ont dit c'est
la bnc vous soyez à me dire laquelle
s'est enfin attendez je le cherche
et entre les deux labels médiane que
michael alors vous prenez l aiguille
creuse et une aiguille et désinfectent
largement la zone de fonction non pas du
tout j'ai fait une piqûre hier le
premier revers un gros hématome et le
deuxième étant déjà plus petit parce
qu'à chaque fois je me réfère au plus
tôt et nous resservent là vous allez
mettre les billets sur votre corps les
juges ont parfois fait une lecture en
fait planter à aiguille le sort et les
blindes de face à je suis pas très bien
avec le sang ça me rend pas très bien si
vous pouvez le faire vous devrez
peut-être les nuits jouets oubliés je
vais vous dire ce qu'il faut faire à
distance
j'aurais dit en fait les jeunes étaient
supposément la force des mollets il
n'est pas adapté
il m'a un truc bizarre la prise de
rendez vous avez maintenant j'attends
les jeunes impliqués moi même à la fin
on fait donc on a fait je vous regarde
fait jeter comme moi je veux faire ça
parce qu'on échange journée non j'avais
carrément vous faites des zélateurs à
vos clients suivants si je me rate cette
couleur dans la missive mais des deux
majeurs mais je sais au moins une au
gain du mali pour mes sapiteur alors
aujourd'hui on peut aussi librement et
dans le terrible est que même moi une
piquette est ce que vous y croyez
franchement très peu de temps ben moi je
n'attends rien du tout on n'est pas sur
youtube pour faire une prise 220 v comme
ça il ya quelqu un qualifié qui prend
l'option s'est jamais fait
si vous partez là moi ça va faire
l'argent donc si vous voulez moi je suis
pas très bon pour les pêcheurs mais je
vous fais un peu dosé comme ça je
comprends pas le malentendu je veux
traiter caméra cachée avons raté une
petite caméra cachée
bon tout ça était à prendre à la
rigolade mais n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez réellement donner votre sang
blanche
la guillotine soleil